okay we're back here on whatever we're
back on Michael should Republicans in
down-ticket races embrace Trump or run
away from him in what they're going to
do is they're going to assess likely to
not be as close as they want or would be
otherwise because of the baggage that
he's bringing on on immigration and a
bunch of other issues so yeah I think
you're going to see a lot of down ballot
candidates you know to begin to see that
say you know what I don't need to go to
the convention I don't need to have you
come into the district and we'll see how
that plays out Paul Begala should
Hillary use Bill more as the campaign
heats up or is he too much of a
liability he's a he's a total asset and
I think you'll see him a lot
particularly in those Rust Belt states
where Trump is strong his appeal
especially with like white working-class
guys it's just a heart of the Trump they
all voted for Bill Clinton twenty years
ago he can get a lot of them at least
talk to them and try to get them off of
there crazy I I want to see him out
there a lot yeah but does Hillary sure
how is his health I have to say I'm
concerned he doesn't look good but you
know is now years since he had the heart
surgery but he's doing but he's doing
great he needs to eat a cheeseburger Wow
if they insane everybody mocked him when
he was eating McDonald's and now they're
mocking him because he only eats you
know bean burrito right cuz there's a
there's a happy medium he's doing great
it's bad okay okay gradually he's off to
you know he's always off to Africa
especially where his foundation is
saving millions lies him he travels all
the time he just works his butt off okay
shoe and I'm just gonna call you shoe is
that what your people want to take what
I can get do people call you it no but
it seems like it's a short for a shoes a
cat look at that one day bum if you saw
how it was spelled you'd feel sorry for
me it's not helpful disability at all x
iu h dez c atl yeah you good luck with
that uh i think she is a good name what
can one person do to influence global
climate policy i'd like to think that
there's more than one person that cares
about influencing global climate policy
so i say get involved with people around
you make a difference it's it's about
one of the greatest issues of our time
you know so one person can get involved
and connect with other people in their
community to make a difference get
involved with politics giving them all
the business get involved with science
whatever it is that you're passionate
about getting engaged with that to make
a difference that's that's what i gotta
say yeah hey man how do we a better
question is how do we clone more kids
like you well i think the good thing is
that we don't have to because at least
in my personal experience I've met
millions of young people all over the
world well that might be an exaggeration
I met a lot of young people all over the
world that are already thinking the way
that you know I've been thinking my
entire life and are ready for change
they're ready for change I mean our
voices are have been systemically
disempowered since the day that we're
born we're not gonna make a difference
until you graduate college and you get a
career then you'll contribute to society
but the way that I see is we're one of
the most powerful forces on the planet
right now great we got to use that yeah
are you just no one would think this guy
was 16 yeah if you didn't know masters
like remember when LeBron was first in
the India who's like this guy's 32 he's
a he's a kidding he came out of high
school here but how are you dealing with
the system I mean your passion and your
energy is contagious
how is it being received by the system
itself I mean whether it's whether it's
at the local level in state level the
government's that you that are going to
be making the policy exactly so I mean
working with the system because
obviously if I just like stood of the
street with a sign and a bullhorn like
where am I gonna get you know that's
part of it but at the same time that's
why I'm in a federal lawsuit holding our
federal government accountable for
violating our constitutional right to
health the atmosphere I'm working with
the system on a legal level I'm working
on the system with a political level
I've been a voice for my generation at
the United Nations I'm on Bill Maher
like there's all these crazy things that
are happening getting me out in the
mainstream
you know you talked to built with Bill
earlier about music art and culture and
how that reaches your generation who's
doing that right in your generation
who's reaching your your age cohort
through music art and culture to make
them care about the fact that the planet
planet is on fire well personally I know
a lot of artists that I listen to
personally that are already on the right
track you know my homie Rory's in the
audience my friend Mustafa they're in
the audience and they're here and
they're artists that are already
thinking how can we use this passion
that we have these talents that we have
how can we get Kanye ting know Wow about
this I think I think there's a lot of
other people we can focus on that aren't
Kanye they are more like
I love the crowd turning out good very
go he's right to shout out to Rory I had
him on my show he's amazing
yeah awesome but but Kanye would be a
tough one to turn around because he's
very into materialism yeah The Bling is
very very important well I mean how do I
support attainable big part of rap
culture yeah I think you got out you
know it's hard to rap about not having
yeah ha ha ha thought he or mother Larry
as someone with experience in sitcoms
late night and sketch TV shows which
format offers the best opportunity for
social criticism well late night
television for direct social criticism
it's harder to do it in sitcoms um on
the family it was a blackish
pretty-pretty
blackish we have done those jobs
involved with awesome right and from the
beginning we wanted that show to be a
show about a black family where The
Cosby Show oh that's hard to mention a
Cosby without God why what happened the
cognition the car wash you refer to no
no thanks but The Cosby Show was a show
about a family that happened to be black
we're blackish was like no [ __ ]
were black and there and that was the
big difference you know so it was taking
a race without apology you know and
creating stories that are universal
family stories without apology but it's
harder to do than sit comes I think the
late night format is the most directly
to do sanitarium ok does Bernie saying
he will vote for Hillary that was news
yesterday have an impact on the Bernie
voters who have yet to get behind the
presumptive Democratic nominee and it
was a bit of a mixed message Bernie gave
I couldn't quite figure it out he is
staying in the race but he's voting for
not him he said this morning he said
this morning he's still running for
president but he will now be voting for
himself for president so I imagine too
many bros are a little baffled yeah um I
would find that perplexing uh at this
point like I just feel like people are
kind of over the Bernie thing a little
bit maybe uh we know Clinton's gonna be
the nominee it's kind of done I'm not
sure I mean there's just so much the
media attention has shifted completely
away from his campaign
instead of feeling the burn you want you
to sense the burn the magic about this
we saw this with Hillary and Barack even
the most important thing is when looked
like Senator Obama was going to win he
pulled back and he told his team it
let's stop attacking her let's give her
the time and space to finish her right
if you watch that's what Hillary did
with Bernie - it's a sign of respect but
now they're going to have to come
together and and thing will they really
will and as I said earlier his voters
have a smaller percentage of his voters
today say they'll never be for Hillary
then Hillary's voters said about Barak
the challenge will be to motivate them
she got crushed with young people by
Bernie she's got to find a way to
motivate them she's got to get your
slightly older big brothers and sisters
out and he will be central to that
that's why her team is giving him a
little space like even though even
though he didn't become our president
like he stirred things up you know he
really stirred things up especially
among the younger generation right yes
we'll never be able to forget that and
we are respected but the question is can
Hillary capture that kind of energy and
sustain it and that's that's something I
just don't think she can because I don't
think it's in her nature to be in that
space that Bernie ashiness always is
she's running I completely secure that I
think think so
I think it's a race between alien versus
Predator I think Hillary that that
political machine the Clintons is a
killing political machine it is anything
that's been the chiller he knows better
no Hillary Hillary cuz it should not be
underestimated she's smart she's
confident she knows exactly what she's
doing
she'll show that either but but but she
like Donald Trump creates her own drag
as well and and so the question going
into the campaign when it begins in
August well is how much drag does she
create given all those variable vote
machine won't you've seen a herd dress
I'm not taking away from anything that
you just said but I'm just I just that's
part of it but her drag is all old drag
yeah all stuff that Trump creates new
drag every day exactly I think I think
part of the problem for Hillary is that
all of her strengths are not things that
translate into getting tons of you know
18 and 1/2 year olds to show up at
rallies like Hillary is really good at
having a wonky detailed conversation
about how to fix that opioid epidemic
like nobody's gonna be like her a
gradual change as far as the student
loan crisis I can't wait for the tax
code to be slightly tweaked yes I mean
people don't stand in line for hours but
she has a secret weapon Donald J Trump
he's gonna be the greatest turnout
machine the Democrats have ever had and
then she's also having to President
Obama and she also has her other she got
him running meetings right she will be
too
and so that's right don't underestimate
that either yes but see his voters
Donald Trump's voters this is all they
do is like [ __ ] about their prostate
and vote they're very loyal yeah yeah
okay that's true my people they're hard
to turn out do you need more later right
work organization where else it's gonna
be brexit to yes that's right but that's
like charismatic candidates work for
Democrats more because I they are
talking I love with me buddy all those
yeah yeah O'Brien's thank you right yeah
we don't need to love you we just need
you there so we just wanted to Bill
Clinton philosophy I said Democrats want
to fall in love Republicans just want to
fall in line right right doesn't have
fallen in line just leaves you there
they do who do you think or hope would
be her veep pick if you can like have
you it's not any idea see the promise I
think about the election and it's a
governing issue the vice president has
never really mattered even Sarah Palin
didn't tank McCain even Dan Quayle
didn't tank George HW Bush even Lloyd
Bentsen couldn't save Mike Dukakis it's
in my lifetime I'm 55 I know that makes
me ancient my lifetime has never been
outcome-determinative
so you should actually pick somebody who
god forbid you die could actually run
the country 21 percent of our presidents
got there cuz the president died or
resigned so you got to think about it
that way you can't just be oh who help
me carry my you know Kentucky you know
it that's what I know her in over 25
years she's sitting there saying god
forbid I die who could take over god
willing I live who could be a governing
partner the way I think Biden has been
wonderfully for President Obama and will
use that's how you have to do that and
who cannot suck all the oxygen out of
the Rada through me like Elizabeth and
that's why Elizabeth Rowan won't be on
the Texas generation about that binds
very well that's why she won't because
listen nobody wants to be the bride and
have the bridesmaids deal correct right
oh this isn't him that's why they
dressed the bridesmaids in shitty car
so last week your ritter sizing
republican senate leaders for running
into the elevators you know the morning
or trump says something stupid Elizabeth
Warren does that every day on Capitol
yeah right yeah like if you're a
reporter and you're sticking out votes
and you want to ask her how are you
voting what's an important issue to you
I mean it's like she Sprint's there's a
staffer behind her she automatically
gets a phone call like oh man how can
mediate you got a phone call whenever a
reporter walks up to you and like I
understand that he'll reporters are
little socially awkward and don't always
have the best personal hygiene we're not
we're not terrible and and just seeing
the fact that she just totally
stiff-arms reporters and only ones to
talk to them in like a TV setting I find
really troubling um and if I had
anything to say about Hillary's veep pic
I hope she picked somebody who doesn't
treat journalists you know well like
they have like had a press conference
yeah okay and but I don't you know what
I can't blame her cuz if she does it
would just be [ __ ] stupid question
yeah but like but all these got a
[ __ ] media all these guys talk to
reporters
go Tigers I'm Tim Kaine talks about Ted
Cruz will talk to you for like half an
hour of course but every question is
about emails and not in Ghazi and you
know I know [ __ ] it up you know it's not
a bad okay thank you very much
you